it gags I'm Sally but you can call me
salamander if you like to you welcome to
the real rejects channel where we are
obsessed with movies one of them being
the amazing spider-man and the whole
entire spider-man franchise he's so cute
anyhoo there was a subscriber that
mentioned I kind of look like Mary Jane
Watson and what I mean kind of I mean
now there's a Twitter page trying to get
me to become Mary Jane Watson in the
next vitamin movie and there's also a
petition oh my god you guys are freaking
crazy and I thought it was really funny
I mean I know some how Hollywood works
but me being an actress out here like
why not so I was thinking I wonder how
powerful you guys actually are on the
internet so I have a challenge for every
single person watching this video right
now the petition for me to become Mary
Jane Watson and the amazing spider-man 3
movie is actually in the description you
can click on it all you have to do is
like sign up really quick and then just
sign the petition because the challenge
is this if we reach 500 signatures on
this petition then I will go on a
massive Twitter spree and follow
everyone who tells me to follow them so
along with signing the petition I would
like you to follow me on Twitter at
Sallie Lamonica also follow the actual
Twitter account for me becoming Mary
Jane Watson yeah I get it's just my
wonderful and slash subscribers the big
one a thousand signatures if this
happens to get a thousand signatures
which I don't know if you guys can do it
you have to prove me wrong I really know
about this but if you reach that goal
then I'll film a spider-man and Mary
Jane short in this short will be my
interpretation of how a couple scenes in
the next movie should go or at least how
they should meet I will do my research
and I will write up a script and I will
film it and it'll be awesome and Ryan
and Jerry will help me and it'll be so
cool and i will play Mary Jane Watson
and I'll hire a hot guy to play
spider-man so along with the short I'll
put every single person's name that
signed in the credits so if you signed
the petition and you'll see your name in
the video which will be basically if
someone gets someone big enough to talk
about this or mention it or contact me
and I will do something huge for you and
I'll pick a couple of people that have
really
so this whole Mary Jane Watson me being
her process and I will send you guys a
lovely prize so that's the challenge I'm
wondering if you guys actually reach it
because I'm gonna give you till the day
I graduate I'm graduating high school on
the 27th of May so as a graduation
present
if you can do this for me that would be
awesome so you have told me 27 to get a
thousand signatures or 500 as much as
you could do and get a really famous
person to respond and you could probably
do that either through Twitter or tumblr
go crazy on the social media sites with
this and we'll see what happens
thank you so much for watching all the
links from you know my Twitter or my
other channel you can subscribe to that
because I'll probably post the
spider-man one on that one and on the
real rejects if we reach a thousand
signatures so follow everything all in
the description all on my face and I
will talk to you guys later I love you I
was so excited for this you guys are so
amazing oh and by the way check out this
one video that one of my subscribers did
he was just trying to get people to sign
the petition and I laughed so hard it
made my day you should sign it check it
out right here and I will talk to you
guys later bye